Allow me to introduce myself.
I’m a writer, journalist
and a socialist.
I also used to be broke.
I did, for a long time.
Being a student,
trying to make a name for myself
in the media industry
and starting a media organization.
I had to move 15 times in 15 years
because the rent in London
just kept on going up.
Now, this taught me
an important lesson, firsthand.
Namely, you can want to study
public policy or astrophysics,
you can want to make a name for yourself,
you can want to do an honest day’s work.
But all of that
is extraordinarily difficult
if your mind is thinking
about those unpaid bills.
Or knowing, with the fullness
of your heart,
that when you go to the cashpoint,
it's going to respond
"Insufficient funds."
Now, while I was going through all this --
which, I have to say, happened
a little bit too long for my liking --
I agreed with the ideas that I was reading
from the liberal tradition,
namely that individuals
are uniquely placed
to determine how their lives
should unfold -- nobody else is.
For everybody in this room,
the best person to decide
how your life should unfold is you.
There’s no higher authority,
certainly not the state.
But what was equally clear
was that, in the absence of access
to certain resources --
education, transport,
health care and housing --
that capacity for self-authorship
is clearly limited for many people.
We clearly live in a society
where what we view as liberty,
the pursuit of happiness,
is limited for the majority
of the global population.
For many, it's illusory.
It turns out that liberal ends
of self-authorship,
of determining
how your life should unfold,
require socialist means.
The state must get involved.
Now, we live in a world where capitalism
has completely prevailed.
It's won.
I was asked, behind stage,
"What are you wearing?"
I said, "Chanel Allure."
And I'm the communist.
(Laughter)
OK? So I'm under no illusions --
it has completely prevailed.
And the ideas driving it
are those of economic liberalism.
Economic liberalism
says what I've just said to you.
The individual is uniquely placed
to determine how their life unfolds,
and that this should happen
through the market.
But there's a problem.
While the market
can be an extraordinary resource
to get the things you need to get
to be who you want to be,
for many, it's the opposite.
It’s a source of un-freedom.
It's a constraint.
It's more akin to a system of rationing
than of prosperity.
We know this is the case
for an increasing number of people,
because the numbers don't lie.
In 2018, 40 million Americans
used food stamps --
13 million more than in 2007,
before the global financial crisis.
Clearly, something is broken.
You can disagree with me
about everything else,
but those are the facts.
In the UK, a much smaller country,
in 2016, 17 million people of working age
had 100 pounds or less savings.
They are one minor accident
away from penury.
17 million people of working age.
And on the thing that capitalism
asks to be judged by,
global growth,
it says, "All this terrible stuff happens,
inequality, poverty, whatever --
but we've still got growth."
Well, actually, the story
isn't so great there either.
Despite the rise of China,
global growth is in secular decline.
So, to be clear, the global economy
is still growing,
but at a smaller, slower rate,
decade on decade.
20 years ago, if you said
the term "lost decade,"
you were talking about Japan.
My apologies to anybody here
of Japanese heritage.
Today, it's an appropriate term
for much of the global economy.
From Britain to Italy,
South Africa to Brazil,
as one lost decade becomes two.
And it gets worse.
This economic malaise
we've seen over the last 15 years
is surely to be joined
by the climate crisis,
and then, demographic aging,
a crisis of elderly care.
It turns out that the opening decades
of the 21st century,
as bad as they were, for many,
are merely the leading edge
of a hurricane.
Now ...
despite everything I've just said to you,
I'm an optimist.
I believe that humans have the ingenuity
to address all of these challenges
and reach unprecedented prosperity
and liberty for all.
That can happen by employing the state
and leveraging the technology revolution.
I wrote a book about it.
It's called "Fully Automated
Luxury Communism."
(Laughter)
The c-word.
Fully automated, because we need
an economic system
which reduces the necessity of human labor
in the production process.
Luxury, because we need to expand
the sense of liberty
and leisure time for all.
Communism, because what I believe
is heading our way this century, maybe,
could see the end
of production for exchange
and the necessity of humans
to sell their labor for a wage.
But in politics,
big ideas only get you so far.
That's been a problem
for the Left historically,
I don't know if you know.
And what matters
in the here and now, in 2022,
are concrete proposals.
So how do we leverage
the technology revolution?
How do we employ the state
to address all the challenges
I've just spoken about,
which I'm pretty sure everybody
in this room would acknowledge?
Rising inequality,
the climate crisis, demographic aging.
For some, the answer
is a universal basic income,
a UBI.
Now, despite being a millennial,
and still petrified
when I look at my bank balance,
I'm not a fan.
And the reason is an affordable
UBI is ineffective,
and an effective UBI is unaffordable.
My proposal, instead,
is universal basic services,
UBS.
These are services
which are universally available,
free at the point of consumption
and paid for through progressive taxation,
a bit like the NHS in the UK.
I propose four of these universal
basic services --
health care, housing,
transport and education.
Why these four?
Housing, because you can't focus
on long-term problem-solving,
or making something of yourself,
if you have to move every 12 months.
Believe me, I know.
Health care, because the basis
of everything else
is physical and mental well-being.
Education, because you can't be
of service to your community
if you don't have skills,
and we need to start acknowledging
that an educated society is a public good.
People training as dentists,
as midwives, as engineers --
hey, as accountants.
We need those people.
Society needs those people,
with those skills,
to not just thrive, but to survive,
and we all benefit
from them having those skills.
Transport, because you can
have the skills,
you can have the housing,
but location can remain a constraint
on access to opportunity.
So, you might agree with me so far,
you might say, "Aaron, I get it.
Market failure exists, it's a thing.
And yeah, OK, the state should intervene
in some areas, fine.
But why universal?
Surely, we should focus scarce resources
on those that need help the most."
It turns out that two academics
gave a pretty good answer to that,
20 years ago.
Surprise, they were Swedish.
And they found that countries
with universal welfare systems
saw the lowest rates of hardship,
the lowest rates of inequality,
and universal welfare systems
commanded the broadest possible consent.
If you want to see the citation,
it's Walter Korpi and Joachim Palme.
Go on Google Scholar, find it.
Now, how does that work?
Why is that the case?
Well, it turns out
that universal welfare systems,
because of the nature of how they work,
have less bureaucracy.
Because they don't employ means testing,
there's less stigma attached,
so the people accessing resources
actually use them,
as opposed to what we get
with means testing,
where you feel like you shouldn't
be doing that.
And importantly,
they have the buy-in
of that political class
that is all-important in democracy,
the middle class.
There's a reason why the NHS in Britain
is still around after 80 years,
and it's so loved.
It's because everybody gets to use it.
It's part of the national fabric.
It’s part of our shared
social conversation and space.
It’s something that belongs
to all of us in the UK,
and we're very proud of it.
So if you want welfare services
which address hardship,
reduce inequality,
are effective, efficient
and broadly liked,
make them universal.
"OK, I like universal services,
but how do we pay for this?"
In a word, tax.
Hardly reinventing the wheel, I know.
In the United States, in the 1950s,
the top rate of tax was 90 percent.
Today, it's 37 percent.
In the UK, for much
of Margaret Thatcher's premiership,
the top rate of tax was 60 percent.
Today, it's 45 percent.
Dwight Eisenhower and the Iron Lady --
hardly two radical Marxists.
And then, there's things
like financial transactions tax.
All the outrage, in fact,
that we tax work more than we tax wealth,
which is astonishing.
In the UK and the US,
capital gains are taxed
lower than incomes.
How the hell does that work?
Talk about a rigged system,
Then, there's the issue
around the technology revolution.
And this is a big reason
why I like universal basic services.
If I'm right,
then the trends in the 21st century
are deflationary.
Energy, information, labor
are getting cheap,
they're deflationary,
and they'll remain deflationary
for a very long time.
Hard to believe, I know, in 2022,
when you're filling up at the tank,
but renewables trends are clear,
and that will be the case
for a very long time.
Now, do we want those trends
to underpin universal basic services,
or prop up shareholders,
or create the basis
for new monopolistic models?
Finally, on the climate crisis,
another reason
for universal basic services.
A UBI would be an extraordinary amount
of money to spend.
And yet, I don't see
quite what it would do
in terms of transitioning our economies
away from fossil fuels,
which again,
I'm sure everybody
in this room acknowledges,
we have to do pretty damn quickly.
Meanwhile, with universal basic services,
we can put a post-carbon agenda
at the heart of education, health care,
transport and housing,
rapidly decarbonizing our economies.
And look, to move away from fossil fuels,
we need to do the one thing
that market fundamentalists hate,
and that's called planning.
So, cast your minds to 2100,
and a world after capitalism
as we know it.
You go to your job four hours a day
in an elderly care center,
one of the few labor-intensive industries
that's still around.
Afterwards, you go for lunch,
you see your friends
and you talk about taking that holiday
in some rewilded forest somewhere,
go see some bison and some bears.
And you talk about wanting to study
for that third college degree,
this time in medicine,
because you're working with older people
and you're fascinated
by the sphere, the area,
the growth industry
of radical life extension.
And hey, your first two degrees
didn't cost a thing,
and that second one,
East Asian Literature,
gave you a whole new perspective on life.
You really loved
Japanese poetry after that.
Pretty good, right?
You get a notification
as you leave that lunch.
Your local health care clinic's saying
you need to go for a quick checkup.
You go down there, you take a bus --
free, electric, self-driving.
The local bus co-op uses
a powerful predictive algorithm
to determine how much supply
is needed at what time
for optimal efficiency and effectiveness.
Compare that to rush hour in LA or London.
Big difference -- I know which I prefer.
You end up at the local health clinic.
They say, "Look, it's time
for liquid biopsy.
You missed your checkup last week."
You go in -- stage zero cancer.
No problem, some pills will fix that.
At every stage of this narrative,
the health care, the transport,
the college degrees, the elderly care,
we've seen universal
basic services in action.
Universally available,
free at the point of consumption
and paid for through progressive taxation.
Now, this might sound utopian.
Personally, I think
it's technically easier to do
than colonizing Mars,
but our society
somehow thinks differently.
But it's not utopian.
In fact, in many ways,
this world resembles our own.
There are still markets
for many, many things.
The state isn't involved
in making chocolate bars
or socks or silk ties.
But it is the central player
in these four things
we all need for liberty:
housing, education,
health care and transport.
And to say it's no utopia
means bad things still happen, yes.
There are fallings out,
there's personal enmity,
there are love affairs,
you fall in and out of love.
Often, falling in love is worse,
it's more dangerous.
These things still happen,
but they're better than homelessness,
than being unable to pay for your insulin,
or failing to address
the climate crisis as a species.
It’s time we lived up
to those glorious words:
life, liberty and the pursuit
of happiness.
And recognize that, for the majority
of the global population,
the pursuit of happiness is impossible.
It's downright illusory,
unless they have access
to universal basic services.
This is the way by which
we guarantee liberty for all
and address the great challenges
of the 21st century --
the climate crisis,
inequality, demographic aging --
whilst leveraging
these remarkable technologies
that the ingenuity
of our species has created.
I don't think there's another way
of addressing those challenges.
I think anybody who thinks otherwise
is delusional, frankly.
But all that means
we're going to have to do something
which, for the political establishment
and status-quo thinking,
has been anathema for decades.
And that means returning the state --
yes, the state --
to the center stage
of our economic and social lives.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: Thank you, Aaron.
I think we have
a secret questioner somewhere,
in the form of Maja Bosnic,
who is a public finance expert.
She spoke recently at TEDWomen.
Maja, what's your question?
Maja Bosnic: Yes, thank you very much.
So my question is basically
related to resistances.
I work with public services,
and I work towards making them
more gender-responsive,
so I know a thing or two
about resistances.
So I wanted to ask you, what do you see
as the biggest resistances?
And in which one,
or maybe some of these four
that you are mentioning?
Thank you.
Aaron Bastani: Great question, thank you.
For me, it’s got to be housing.
Because, particularly
in the Anglo-American economies,
we have a growth model
built upon speculative investment
in housing assets.
The reality is, for the likes
of the UK and the US --
the Canadian property market
is probably quite similar --
we need to have something
akin to what Japan has seen
over the last 25 years,
which is, effectively,
flat house price increases.
Sorry, I should phrase that better --
zero percent growth in house prices.
So wages can catch up.
I saw an amazing statistic, actually,
the other day in the UK,
which showed that a majority
of homeowners in the UK
are happy to have zero growth
on house prices.
And that makes sense.
Why would you want
your house to gain in value?
All it means is you buy another house,
which has relatively gone up as well.
And I think people acknowledge
that this isn’t working
for people who rent,
who don't own the assets.
And I would rather keep that price flat,
and, you know, have more people
included in our economy.
But that's, I think,
the big structural challenge --
we would have to take on
speculative investment in housing.
CA: Thank you, Maja.
Aaron, I'm really taken
by this argument for UBS,
partly because, just structurally,
some of those things
naturally get organized better
if there's only one of them,
not a bunch in competition.
You compare US health care capitalism
with something like the NHS
or the state things,
which, for all their faults,
seem to deliver equally good
or better health care
for, like, half the money.
Transport, you can make the same argument.
But have you cost it out?
To roll out all these four,
that's a massive investment.
Have you costed it?
AB: I haven't costed it.
University College London
has costed universal basic services,
and they had six -- they included food,
which is pretty ambitious.
In the US private health care system,
16 percent of GDP's spent on health care.
In the UK, it's 10 percent.
And we have longer life expectancy,
fewer women dying in childbirth,
lower infant mortality.
So clearly, something is going right.
And you might say,
"The NHS is underfunded."
Bump up by one or two percent.
And of course, we have universal coverage.
So there's a strong argument there
for public health care,
from an efficiency perspective --
(Applause)
AB: Thank you.
And I would respond with this,
in regards to elderly care.
If you look at the crisis
of demographic aging,
and elderly care
that’s coming down the line
because of lower birth replacement rates
of an aging population.
And I want one of these geniuses
to come up with us living to 200.
But if that happens,
we then create a crisis of elderly care,
and the reality is, it's not
that we can't afford to do UBS,
a UBS of elderly care, if that happens --
we can't afford not to do it.
Because I then return
to the NHS point about efficiency,
particularly in elderly care.
If you don't have that as a UBS,
you're in big trouble, in my view.
CA: Aaron, thanks for an incredibly
compelling contribution to the debate.
AB: Thank you, cheers.
(Applause)